hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay um we need to
go into this mysterious door to do
something I don't know I don't even
remember getting an objective I thought
I was supposed to move the marker going
in here oh this look oh boy yeah that's
this like ooh look at this
twirl yeah oh look at me run
why the gutter pwned
all these fan blades look terrible hi
what are these limbs everywhere hey baby
are they gone
seem to be missing ha ha
give me that I like I sure do like to
mock my enemies makes me feel superior
oh boy my brain Oh gravity business
serious business ok whoa and then leave
I said leave I said leave come on how
else am I supposed to go there we go all
my brain
oh I leave done ok lupa do hi
why am I here it's the point it's the
purpose pull this down restore power
sure why not
lights were on and everything I don't
know why the power was off power
activated okay oh I turned on the fans
uh-huh
ah
good thing they had all these spaces oh
ha ha ha
baby do bad I'm I'm just running get out
of here
get out of here
Oh roh-roh
sprint to the finish like a mouse
soccer balls can't catch me what no I
don't even need to jump there whoops go
around ha ha I win go cry to your mama
I'm the best I'm the best I had that big
one I got contact beam just for you
hello Oh what that cases oh right your
shoulder
[ __ ] another one and that's going in for
another one
gotya black eyeballs I can't
once I charge it up again release ha ha
you didn't even stand a chance why did
you even try why did you get up in the
morning if you knew you're gonna face
Marc Clark you can't survive against me
cannot survive cuz I'm the best
oh yeah getting the marker that's why I
originally came here all right got
distracted but this is killing this big
guy come on ma'am
come on way bigger
fassl fatty Patterson sorry Kevin Kevin
good what the hell go kami go
there we go there we go
all right hit the safe station just in
case what walk walk walk there
all right now
and ramming speed
was that long
now why do they build this whole base
resources
there we go pop okay now what's up
don't trust him don't trust him
don't jump I don't care if you were
totally forgotten is his name Isaac's
friends okay okay don't touch it don't
touch it if I saw my friends dead bodies
when there's an alien infestation that
takes over dead bodies I'd probably do
the same don't say you all wouldn't
either about survival let's go areum
Goody's you ain't gonna stop me from
getting my duties here why was that that
boxwood moving I thought there was gonna
be squiddy's no let's go on surprise
I guess not
open one potato no go back to potato
cryptid Oh
walk tale
Oh Oh we're outside okay finally well
actually I should say we're outside
Moe's at what is that what is that what
is that I see it I see it
I see something what is that I saw it oh
wow okay bye bye
alright that's cool thank gravity oh
look at that
hello that's an asteroid hurt no that's
the of the peace of this planet that
they popped up pop into cork as they
said okay now take this guy then we
watch the goodies more goodies goodie
goodie goodie gimme gimme don't trust
you trust you
there we go yeah there we go
and here we go
Hey who did that
busy busy walk
haha
you
Hey hello
yeah that's all you got that all really
are the sponsors stopping me
I hate it
I heard that there you are yo dad just
like that
oh pedestal what's in there look
like the marketer him
I wonder now get out of here
another one snipe your arms gone there
we go now push it the grub
Oh Isuzu oh I thought those are paradise
cool I can't give it then again how did
that kill you
cool
Thank You Isaac oh she's good I always
believed in you yeah whatever
I knew you'd return to me crazy we are
whole again Isaac crazy we are whole you
so cray-cray and you're gone yeah you
were all it
all right
the urgency key orbital gravity tethers
offline why a conic load released in act
limited why evacuate this area
immediately
why why did you release it oh look at
that that getting brighter holy crap it
is all tendering atmosphere okay that
makes sense that was a case that thing's
gonna hit in like two minutes so we're
all boned
I probably shouldn't be waiting around
standing looking at okay
here we go we high hotel the hell hi
oh ah no I don't like decontamination
cycle I'm clean I'm clean enough get out
of here you're dirty oh hello how did
you get here yeah kind of did uh-huh
noni yeah it is I'd like you to move
yard Hey no you're insane take a look at
yourself take a look at the video very
cool how handsome I am this time try to
the end
nice pistol gather I got something I
don't I wish I could talk to you
I'm sorry I'm sorry about everything
yeah wish I could talk someone both on
your partyís message company
I'm strange it's a little thing man I
contracted one little thing okay yeah
that makes sense I didn't want it to end
like this
I really wanted to see you again just
once yeah
I left you
I always loved you
yeah that makes sense
oh boy
yep
hmm
oh what's that Isaac Isaac's showing
some emotion just like the captain yeah
they call it in dead this whole time
you're in st. Jude you're a Jarman but
don't worry you'll be following this
damn place hmm
boom goodbye - you take one of these
have a good vibe prison yeah
okay I guess I got to cut her off
yeah oh you like you hang you
how's that big ol yep that looks
dangerous I love me some goop a power
note I thought I have anything left
upgraders dupa do slurping through some
goofy uses all yeah oh come on get some
stop it
there was corn okay oh where am I
we're goodies goodies more everything up
not one more here we go drew oh I'm back
here okay alright me I got partner let
me see if there anything else like a
popper with possibly up
okay that's full got that for on HP it's
good upgrade the plasma cutter if I
really want
it's just not much left to upgrade uh I
kiss the air cuz that's gonna be so
useful I'm sure there's gonna be another
no air sequence sometime in the near
future
yeah okay I gotta I feel like a minha
cool it's time for the save point there
I okay point point point okay and that's
all the time I got for this episode
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye